the important thing to say is um well
crisper is just a new form of Technology
basically it's just another platform um
for doing something that we were doing
before um the best analogy actually I
have for this is it's a bit like the
first smartphone to mobile phones and
communication in general telephones
existed before mobile phones existed
before but we all kind of remember
probably the first Apple iPhone that
came out and thinking okay this is a
total game Cher and it is so crisper
crisper cast 9 as it's called is a game
changer because um of its Precision
importantly okay it's significantly more
precise um and programmable than
previous generations of Technology
available for um altering and modifying
DNA and that Precision means that we can
achieve far greater results it's also
faster to utilize and leverage in the
lab so that's also important and it's
pretty cheap too so all those things
definitely help but the reason why this
has been so revolutionary is because of
this programmable Precision that it
brings um meaning that now
basically anything that we know of uh
that is encoded in DNA whether it's in
plants animals or human beings is up for
modification right so
that's exactly it it's a Precision isn't
it because what we're looking at here is
being able to change the genetic codes
we're talking about the the genetic
alphabet in any species not just humans
and there's something specific about
this specificity isn't there in terms of
the kinds of diseases that this can
impact there's certain kinds of
conditions that this is really really
good for well I mean well yes in
particular
um if you're thinking about human beings
and if you're thinking about the
diseases that human beings get any
disease that we know is attributable to
a single disease to a single um Gene
excuse me in particular is is a is a
prime candidate for this for this
technology because if you know with
certainty this Gene a whatever it is
causes this disease we can now deal with
it of course not all diseases are
attributable to a single disease uh
single Gene excuse me and so you know
there is some limitation there for for
what we could potentially do potentially
yeah yeah yeah okay so this Precision is
what's making it all so exciting but
there are some challenges and there are
some current limitations with the
technology in terms of using it more
widely aren't there and is it is it
simply that that it's too precise to be
able to be used for anything that's more
complicated or or are there other issues
with it no so I think I would say just
so you know just to remind you all I'm
sure you're all aware so crisper cast 9
is a is a or crisper for short is a
two-part molecular system importantly um
there's the crisper bit that's the bit
that's programmable that you can encode
to say this is the piece of DNA I'm
looking for that I want you to go find
and then there's the cast 9 bit and the
cast 9 bit is the sort of doing end of
of the the the setup and what's really
fascinating about this technology is a
bit like um iPhones have changed over
time we've also already started
modifying this platform so you can
change the cast 9 to have different
functions and different um effects
basically
and so there's actually quite a lot that
you can do with this technology in fact
you know the the opp the range of things
that we can do is really quite wide but
um in terms of
limitations um well if you think about
it um crisper can be used to change DNA
but DNA exists in one copy per cell and
each one of us approximately is several
trillion cells moving around through
space which means several trillion
copies of genomes which means if you
want to change something you you you've
got a real delivery problem basically so
the main limitation at the moment or the
big conundrum comes here which is all of
us start off life as one cell and then
we become several trillion cells so we
have this technology it can be used to
edit things in DNA DNA is really
important for health outcomes at what
point do you edit that DNA do you do it
when you are one you know big in a
single cell or do you do it when you are
several trillion cells big and you've
got a real delivery problem right so
therein lies the problem and therein
lies the big ethical conundrums and some
of the big questions that have Arisen
around the idea of things like designer
babies and what so forth but we will we
will come to that I think sorry just to
to to be really explicit about this the
reason why doing an edit on a single
celled embryo is um ethically
questionable or or causes some uh
questions to be raised is just to be
really precise for everyone in the
audience the implication is if you edit
embryos that are really really small you
will edit the cells that will go on to
make the egg and sperm cells in the Next
Generation and so you edit them as well
whereas if you edit a body that already
exists it's called you know somatic you
just change a body you don't necessarily
change the egg and sperm cells so that's
really important that's heritable yeah
yeah and I'm really glad that you made
that distinction because what we're
talking about there is this idea that we
could even poten be editing the
evolution of the human species which
obviously has massive implications but
I'd like to talk to Jimmy now and bring
you into the conversation because in a
way you embody what we're talking about
all of the science that we've just been
talking about which is absolutely
fascinating you've actually had
firsthand experience of What gene
therapy can be like now you lived with a
condition called CLE cell anemia since
you were born I wonder whether you could
just tell the audience here what is it
like to have CLE cell what was your your
experience of it just so that we can
understand why it was so important for
you to have the therapy in the first
place my experience with CLE cell was um
tough it sometimes it felt like you know
climbing Mount Everest stacked on top of
kilamanjaro there was no end in sight uh
constantly living out of hospitals um of
course we all know the Cornerstone of
the disease is constant pain that just
constantly lingers and then all your
organs are also at play in gerp had a
heart attack gallbladder taking out a
vascular necrosis it's just um
insurmountable
odds that actually makes it quite
difficult to live you know so at some
point in my life I found myself really
questioning the quality of my life
whether it's actually even worth living
with everything that's going on with Cel
and um you know with luck I found
crisper I I thought it was going to be a
solution for the future 20 30 years in
the future and luckily I found this
article that came into my inbox and I
qualified you know for something that I
thought was 20 years in the future it
happened 2 years after um you know I'd
had this discussion with my parents to
try and figure out a way to improve my
quality of life and life post transplant
um is surreal it every day I wake up I'm
still in awe I'm still shocked as to
what I'm able to do compared to what my
life was like before uh pre-transplant
you know
the boundless amounts of energy that I
had before I couldn't even climb a
flight of stairs without taking a break
to catch my breath now I need people I
need people to tell me to slow down
because I I just you know I'm constantly
on the go because of how um how crisper
really changed my life it one of the
things I feel like it's really given me
is control you know for as a young man
you know as a teenager or or kid growing
up you feel like your parents kind of
control your life because they're adults
and they kind of direct you and then and
then when you get older you know you get
to this period where you think you're
going to take control of your life but
in my case I didn't have control of my
life as well cell directed every aspect
in which my life went and then you know
as a 35y old man I finally have control
of my life and it it is um
unreal oh Jimmy it's really moving to
hear you talk about the transformative
effect that the gene therapy has had for
you and I'm so glad that you're able to
share the story with us just to clarify
for for the audience who are listening
um so cleal anemia is is a a disease
that is basically caused by genetic uh
alteration in the hemoglobin structure
so that's what forms our blood cells and
when these blood cells are not forming
in the normal way they they become
sickle-shaped and they can have all
sorts of different symptoms and actually
I wonder whether Jimmy you could just
tell us some of the other symptoms as
well as pain that you had and how it
would present for you for you because
again I think it's just really important
for people to understand the impact that
conditions like this can have on
Ordinary People yeah absolutely I would
have these you know really violent pain
episodes that we call CLE cell
crisises that you know it's very
difficult to describe it just feels like
your whole body just is in a a wave of
pain that can last for months you know
where you need intravenous medication in
order to control that pain so that you
know when I lived up north in in in the
Tri Area that particular in the winter
months that would happen almost twice a
week to two times sometimes you know
I'll be living out of the hospital just
to keep this pain under control so
that's one of the most important pieces
of CLE cell is just that const pain and
and when it escalates and becomes
chronic that you desperately need to
seek Hospital help that's when it really
gets bad but then like I said you also
have all because the blood cells are all
your organs basically need good blood
flow back and forth and with cichos you
don't have that good blood flow so I had
a heart attack once because I wasn't
having good blood flow to my heart um my
gallbladder had to be taken out at quite
a young age as well because of the same
similar reason of just not having enough
blood flow to it and then multiple
pulmonary embolisms you know acute chest
syndrome
pneumonia it it's a the disease is
really the way it manifest in your life
and way it Crips into it it's actually
sometimes hard to describe as obviously
having a problem because it it goes into
every facet you know where you grow up
where you where you plant a good go to
school
relationships all of that it's um really
really difficult yeah gosh and you're
illustrating there again just how
important it is to think about disease
affecting every aspect of a person's
life and especially as a child I mean
this started when you were from the day
you were born right um and what what's
really interesting to me and a bit of
your story that I think is really
interesting for the audience to hear is
that when you were a child you were not
in the states right you were in Nigeria
and that's part of why the symptoms were
so catastrophic in terms of the
treatment that you were able to access
and the health care there maybe you
could just talk a little bit about that
and then also then how you then were
able to get onto the crisper trial okay
um so I was actually born here in the
states uh at the time 1985 in Nigeria
they didn't have the amniocentesis test
that would confirm if you have any gen
genetic condition uh my parents were
fortunate enough to fly my my mom over
while she was pregnant to to Washington
DC she had that amoc synesis test which
in fact confirmed that you know I would
have Cel and you know they still decided
to you know bring me to life because
back then I pray my mom told me that you
know the natural C of action it
particularly if you from Nigeria because
people or children with CLE cell in
Nigeria didn't live past the age of five
so you know some doctors they were off
the belief that there is no point in
bringing a child to life that's not
going to see 5 years old but because I
was born here in the US I got really
fortunate you know they gave birth to me
here I became an American citizen and um
you know we went back home like you said
uh to Nigeria for a little bit and there
was there's this one particular story I
think I told you when we uh you know
touched Bas earlier was um I I used to
do this thing as a young boy at the end
of class i' would go in in front of the
chalkboard in front of the chalkboard
and still chalk and I'll find myself
really taking all these weird substances
and taking it home with me and find
myself in the corner eating chalk eating
foam and really thinking I was going
crazy and then I moved over to the
states and that thing that was happening
these behaviors that I was manifesting
leg J turned out to be a condition
called Pika where you are lacking
nutrients so I was lacking a lot of
nutrients because I had cell but you
know it just goes to show like you said
the at the time at least the disparities
in the two Healthcare System in one
country I thought I was nuts and in the
other country it was actually turned out
to be a condition that they were
treating and you know they gave me all
these folic acid and all these things so
you know my body wasn't in need of those
nutrients yeah and you know just to draw
out again that distinction between the
different Health Systems because I think
think this is really important for us to
think about the global inequalities that
exist right in terms of what's available
um you're lucky enough now to be able to
talk to us about all of your experiences
you've had literally a 180 degree
reversal of your fortunes um and I don't
think it's it's exaggerating for me to
say that it has been life-changing for
you yeah but but of course you know that
has come by being uh in this United
States where you've had access to this
Cutting Edge technology and I wonder how
you think about
the Jimmy that might have stayed in
Nigeria or or all the kids who are still
in Nigeria and don't have access to this
how does that make you
feel that's a fantastic question because
um I'm a big believer in um a stoic
principle called a more fatty which is
you know loving one's fate and you know
the irony of me saying this is not lost
on me because I've obviously through on
the other side
but that's that statement simply you
know simp it translated from Latin
simply means you know being happy with
the cards you dealt you know no matter
how tragic your situation is you know if
while I was in the throws of the disease
if someone would have said that to me i'
would have been pissed if I'm honest
um but you know I the truth is I I I
only time will tell I mean I I
definitely feel uh and carry a lot of
guilt too as well for people that are
not going to get to access um what I
have access to at least not in the next
five to six years uh there's
definitely you know me going through the
process itself through a year um I I
don't even I can't even picture how it's
going to be you know transported and
made commercially ready for places like
Africa and India where these therapies
are desperately needed you know I know
they're working on things called inv
Vivo now where we don't have to do the
conditioning that I had to go through so
I'm guessing that's what it's going to
be when these therapies can be taken as
a pale but I can see that still being
not a pill rather just a simple infusion
but I still see that being you know
decades and decades away from happening
hopefully
not
that